Hi, DATA 2100 students.
In this video, we
are going to walk
through this in-class
assignment of Python and SQL,
specifically using insert
and update queries.
We'll also do some select.
But if you have any
questions about this,
make sure that you have already
watched all the videos regarding
the SQL and Python
connection, so that you
are well aware of
what we are doing
and that it doesn't
catch you too off guard
because the programs
we're going to do today
are going to be fairly
intense and going
to cover a lot of the
components that we've
covered thus far in the course.
So just keep that in mind.
Please have already downloaded
the Overland SQLite database
file, and then we're going to be
prepared to load that in today.
So I'm going to come over here
into our in-class assignment.
On program 1 and the
Overland database,
we want to return Penny
Peter's first name, last name,
and ski level.
Penny's employee ID is 12389.
We're going to change Penny's
ski level to advanced,
and then we're going to output
the employee ID, first name,
last name, and ski levels for
the record, we just updated.
So I'm going to come
over here to files,
and I'm going to upload
our Overland SQLite file.
As a reminder, if this
ever does time out
may need to upload that
file one more time.
So let's come on down here.
We're going to copy
in this code up above
and paste it down below.
And let's just run
this and make sure
that it doesn't get any errors.
OK, awesome.
So now I want to return Penny
Peters's information here.
So after I have connected
to that Overland database,
then I'm going to
create a cursor,
and I'm going to
base that cursor,
I'm going to create
that cursor to go
to this connected database.
And this cursor is what runs
my database query for me.
The data is then returned
inside of that cursor,
and I must extract the
data from that cursor using
a fetch all command, which
we'll do in just a second.
So once I've
created that cursor,
then I'm going to
tell the cursor
to go ahead and execute
the following query.
And I know that I want
to return the employee
ID, first name, last name.
So let's look at
this Overland SQL--
oh, no.
No, that's not what I wanted.
Overland.
ERD into a dictionary.
There we go.
We take a look here.
I can see here that
the employee has
the record ID as a primary key.
First name, last name.
And then we have the
ski level as well.
All right.
So I'm going to say
cursor.execute select, RecID,
employee first name, employee
last name, and ski level.
And I want to look specifically.
I'm going to be pulling data
from, let's exit out of there,
from the employee table.
So let's just go
ahead and run this.
And I can see here that
it's just showing me
that the query did run,
but all of the data
is currently contained
within that cursor.
So to grab all the
data out, I'm going
to say results equal
to cursor.fetchall.
So I'm going to retrieve.
Place all output
records from the query
into a list called results.
OK.
Then I will go ahead.
And we'll say for y
in results, print y.
So as a reminder, once I run
this query, all of the data
is stored inside of that cursor.
Then to retrieve
all of that data,
I create a results
variable that is
going to be a list that
grabs all of the data
using this fetchall
method from the cursor
and places them in all of those
tuples inside of my results.
Then I loop through my
results list, and I print y.
So I'm going to go
ahead and run this.
And we can see here that I
have all of my employee data
returned to me.
RecID, employee first
name, employee last name,
and ski level all
outputting to me.
Now this time though, I'm
outputting everything.
But I really just want to look
at employee ID or record ID,
right?
12389.
So I'll say where RecID,
which is the unique identifier
for the employees, is 12389.
So now when I run
this query, you'll
notice that we get
12389, Penny and Peters.
And Penny is currently
an intermediate skier.
So now what I want
to do is after I've
fetched all that
information, then
I want to update Penny's
ski level to advanced.
And the way that I do that
is I say cursor.execute,
and I will update employee.
And I'll set the ski
level equal to advanced,
where the RecID is
equal to that 12389.
So my update command, the most
important part of the update
command is the where clause.
So I update the employee table.
I set the value of the ski level
field to be equal to advanced,
but only on the record that
has the rec ID of 12389.
So now when I, I'm
gonna go back here,
and I'm going to say commit
the changes to the database.
As we've talked
about, I must say,
conn.commit to commit the
changes to the database.
If I don't say this,
then the changes
do not fully commit
to the database.
They will do like
a partial commit,
but that partial
commit will only
last for the duration
of the program.
So in order for me to
fully commit, fully change
the database, I've got
to do that conn.commit.
Then I'm going to run the same
query that I did up here above.
And I want to say return
Penny's updated information.
And I will run that same query.
After again, I run
what it, originally
was I update the ski
level, and then I'm
going to check that the update
was persisted or update worked.
So I'll say maybe output
equal to cursor.fetchall.
I'm going to name my two outputs
from the different queries,
different things.
And then I'll say for
x in output, print x.
OK, let's go ahead and run this.
So now, once I run
this, I can see here
that Penny's information,
database is locked.
OK.
Let's go ahead and
run this one more time
and see if we get
the same error.
OK.
Database is locked.
Let's just come up here and I'm
going to say restart session.
And then I'll need to re-upload.
Let me delete out
my database file.
If you're getting the
same error as I am,
we're just going to basically
refresh our database connection.
So I'm going to re-upload
my database file.
Now when I run this again.
We'll see here that Penny
Peters was originally
an intermediate skier.
Then this update command ran.
Then we said, all right,
rerun this program
and make sure that
the update persisted.
And we can see that it
did, that Penny Peters now
has an advanced ski level.
Awesome.
Now program number 2,
similar to the above, but now
turn the above program into
a ski level update program
that anyone can use to
update their ski level.
The program should welcome the
user to the ski level update
program.
Ask the user, the
employee for their RecID.
Then validate that they did
enter an integer and not
a blink.
Ask them to enter their ski
level, beginner, intermediate,
advanced, or expert.
Verify they entered one
of the four ski levels.
Make their entry
not case sensitive.
Then update their ski level
in the database and output
thank you and then
their first name.
Your ski level is now blank.
All right.
So we've got quite
a bit going on here.
Before we jump down
into this program,
I just want to show you here
really quickly, I apologize.
If we wanted to get this
last print statement out
of this form, I can
say, you know what?
Print the 0 index
value of the x, which
is the tuple, because
our records are
returned to us in tuples and
contained within the output list
now.
The 0 index value of
this tuple is 12389.
The first index value is Penny.
The second index
value is Peters,
and the third index
value is advanced.
So now when we run this, we'll
notice that it did change
in the database.
So the original
query is running--
the ski level is now
advanced to begin with.
Then my update runs again.
It doesn't change anything.
But now this time, at
least it's outputting to me
without being contained
within these parentheses
and within those quotation
marks and things.
All right.
So now here on
program number 2, we
are going to still copy down
this import SQLite3 library.
And then we're going to
paste it down here below
and run the program.
All right.
Then I want to welcome the user
to the ski level update program.
OK.
I'm going to first
off create my cursor
because I know I'm going to be
running some database queries.
So I'm going to say
cursor equals conn.cursor.
OK, perfect.
Now I will print Welcome to
the employee ski level update
program.
Perfect.
OK now, once I want
to do is we want
to validate that they
did enter an integer,
and we're going to
keep asking them
over and over and over again.
But since we're going
to keep asking them,
we know that a while loop
will be involved here,
but we're not going to get
too carried away with that.
We're going to have the while
loop add at the very end.
So I first off want to ask the
user to enter their employee ID.
So I'll say user ID
is equal to input.
What is your employee ID?
And then I want to validate
that they did enter
an integer and not a blank.
So once they entered
that, I am going
to validate that they
did not enter a blank.
So I'll say validate they
The way that I'll
do that is I'll
say if the user ID
is equal to nothing.
So if they entered
a blank, right?
Do this.
I'll say print nothing entered.
You must enter your employee ID.
OK?
So if what they enter is
blank, that should run.
So I'm going to go
ahead and run this.
I'm not going to hit enter
anything into the cell
upon prompt.
So I'll hit enter.
And it says nothing entered.
You must enter your employee ID.
OK, awesome.
If I was to run this again
and I did enter something,
well, then my program
just ends because that
if statement is not true.
Now if my if
statement is not true,
then evaluate what they entered.
Let's see.
Make sure they
entered an integer.
So I know they've
entered something
if this else block runs.
And let's see.
Maybe I'll say if they
entered anything, do this.
Then I will try.
And let's see.
Try to validate they
entered an integer.
OK.
So once this else
block runs, then I'm
going to try and validate
that what they did enter
was indeed an integer.
So the way that I'll do that is
I'll say if the user is equal,
or I'll try and
convert the user ID
to be equal to the integer
value of user ID, OK?
I'm going to indent that.
Something is not liking my try.
So I'm going to just hit tab
and see if that will work.
OK.
One more time here.
My try block.
OK.
Hopefully that will work.
All right.
If not, we'll adjust.
So chart validated that
it did enter an integer.
If they did enter
an integer, I'm
going to say print Thanks
for entering an integer.
As we know, with try and
accept, if this throws an error,
if what they did enter
is not an integer,
so if this cannot happen
then my except block runs,
and the except block says print
You must enter an integer.
OK.
So as long as my if statement
is true, then what prints
is Nothing entered.
You must enter your employee ID.
If my if statement is not true,
meaning they entered something,
then I'm going to
try and validate
that they entered an integer.
So I'll try and convert
their entry to be an integer.
If that works, then I'll print
Thanks for entering an integer.
If that doesn't work, then I'll
say you must enter an integer.
So I'm going to go
ahead and run this.
So what is your employee ID?
I'm going to do a blank for
now, and I'll just hit enter.
It says nothing entered.
You must enter your employee ID.
OK, awesome.
Now what if they enter 17, OK?
So this if statement is
going to evaluate as false
and what is indented and
beneath it will not run.
The else block will run,
and it will try and convert
what they did enter, that
user ID to be an integer.
If this fails, which it
will, this will fail,
and so my except block
will run, and it will say,
you must enter an integer.
So I'll hit enter.
But again, the try and accept
will not let my program crash.
Rather, it just says, oh,
there's an error that occurred.
All right, perfect.
So you must enter an
integer is what ran.
Now this time, let's say 1,
2, 3, and I'll hit enter.
And it says, thanks for
entering an integer.
OK, awesome.
So I know that the base
logic of validating
that they entered an integer and
not a blank as their employee
ID.
I know that this is now working.
So what I'm going to do
is I'm going to put this
all within a while loop.
And I'm going to
say, while true,
and have everything
indented and beneath it.
Oh, no.
So I'll highlight
it all and hit tab.
And I want to break
out of this while loop
once they know that they
have entered an integer.
So I'll say, thanks for entering
an integer, and I will break.
And I'll leave the while loop.
OK.
So let's try this again.
So says welcome to your
skill level update program.
What is your employee ID?
I hit enter.
Nothing entered.
You must enter your employee ID.
Then I say 17, and I hit enter.
It says you must
enter an integer.
OK, perfect.
Then I say 1, 2,
3, and hit enter.
It says Thanks for
entering integer,
and my program finally ends.
Now I don't need to tell my user
thanks for entering an integer.
We're just going to break
out of that while loop
because they've moved on to
the next part of my program.
All right.
Perfect.
So now here below, I'm actually
going to return to this.
This is not part necessarily
of the program prompt,
but I'm going to
print f strings.
Thank you for entering
your employee ID.
And then I'm going to return
the value that they entered.
So I'll say, user ID.
OK?
We'll just say that for now.
So now when I run this again,
we're just going to say 123.
I hit enter.
It says thank you for
entering your employee ID 123.
Awesome.
Now once I've done that, I
need to validate that once
I entered their ski level, that
once they enter their ski level,
that it is an appropriate ski
level, beginner, intermediate,
advanced, and expert.
It's not like they enter
in totally advanced
and that my program
will accept it.
These are four levels
that we will accept.
So we're doing two types of
input validation here, right?
We are validating
whether it's-- well,
we're doing a lot
of input validation.
But up here, we're validating
that what they enter
is not blank and that
it is an integer.
And then down here, we're
validating that what they enter
is one of these
four options, OK?
So super important.
This is how we maintain data
integrity in a database, right?
That we're saying these
are our four options.
So for consistency
here, we only are
going to allow
these four options
to be entered into my database
under their ski level, OK?
All right.
So now what we're
going to do is we're
going to make sure that they
enter one of those four options.
And so I'm going to
ask them, again, we're
going to keep asking them this.
But for now, I am going to just
have this outside of a while
loop for right now.
All right.
So user key level, I'll
say equal to input.
What is your current ski level?
And then they will enter
their current ski level.
We're going to make sure
that their entry is not
case sensitive.
So I'm going to lower their
ski level, all lower case.
And then I'm going to
say, if the user ski level
is one of these three,
then they can go ahead,
and I can update their
record based on that.
Sorry, one of these four.
So I'm going to say
if user ski level.
And then I can
use this handy in,
a keyword that says if user
ski level in intermediate,
in beginner,
advanced, or expert.
If your user ski level is
in one of these values,
so very similar to
what we've done in SQL,
then I want to print, thank you
for entering a valid ski level.
Then what I'm actually
going to do here
is I'm going to place
the update query
to update their ski level here.
But I'm not going to
do that for right now.
But then I'll also commit
changes to the database.
Right now I'm just going
to make these as comments
and make sure that my logic is
working before I start making
all these query updates, OK?
Else, if they did not enter
one of the valid ski levels,
then output this, which is
print invalid ski level.
Please try again.
OK.
So here in my what is
your current ski level?
I actually might put the options
of beginner, intermediate,
advanced, and expert.
So I may just give them that
kind of push, if you will.
So let's go ahead
and run this now.
So what is your employee ID?
I know this is working.
So I'm going to say 123.
Thank you for entering
your employee ID.
Now let's say that I enter
something that's totally
not part of my if statement.
It's not in this set of values.
So I'm going to go
ahead and run this.
It says invalid ski level.
Please try again.
OK, perfect.
Now let's run one that is
in this list of values.
So I'm using this as a
conditional statement.
If user ski levels in one
of these four values, then
print, thanks for entering a
ski level, a valid ski level.
So let's say advanced.
I'm going to hit enter.
It says thank you for
entering a valid ski level.
OK, perfect.
So this is working
like we want it to.
But now here, instead
of saying thank you
for entering a valid
ski level, I actually
want to place the update
query that we're going
to run to make these changes.
So I'll say
cursor.execute f string.
No, stop that.
I don't want to run the program.
OK, f string.
I want to update
the employee table.
Set ski level equal to,
and I must contain this
within single quotes,
just like we did when
we were writing SQL queries.
We talked a lot about this.
But I need to put user ski
level in those single quotes
within the square brackets.
Because this query is
going to be taken directly
from this program and
ran against the database.
And then I'll say where
RecID equal to the user ID
that they entered.
OK.
So I am changing the ski
level to be whatever they
entered their ski level to be.
And then the record
ID is a value
of user idea which they entered,
which is their employee ID.
So I'm only updating
the record where
the user is equal
to whatever they've
entered as their employee ID.
Then I'm going to make sure
that I say conn.commit.
Sometimes, if you do
not have conn.commit,
that database is locked.
Issue will pop up.
So make sure that you
commit the changes.
All right.
Perfect.
Now, once we've
done all of that,
then I can say, let's
go ahead and run this.
Make sure it works.
So what is your employee ID?
I say let's use our friend
Penny up here as our test case.
So I'm going to say,
what is your employee ID?
I'll hit enter.
Thank you for entering
your employee ID.
What is your
current skill level?
And I'll say beginner
and hit enter.
And now my program ends, right?
I think it updated
in the database,
but now I need to prove that
it updated in the database.
So I'll say cursor.execute.
And let's come up here and grab.
Actually, we'll try it again.
We'll say select
RecID, first name.
Employee first name,
employee last name.
Ski level from employee
where RecID equal to user ID.
OK.
Awesome.
Perfect.
Now once I've done this, then
we can say, output results.
And I need to grab all
the data returned to me.
I'll say cursor.fetchall.
And we'll say for
y in outputresults.
Or Print y for now.
So now let's go
ahead and run this.
What is your employee ID?
Let's just paste in
that 12389 of pennies.
Thank you for entering
your employee ID 12389.
What is your
current skill level?
Let's say advanced.
So we're going to
change pennies,
scale back to be advanced.
And what row?
Unrecognized token.
OK.
Up here, make sure that we are
using an f string in my select.
My apologies.
It was like, that's not actually
a thing unless f strings exist.
All right.
So now we'll run 12389.
We'll change pennies
to be advanced.
I'll hit enter.
And now we see that pennies
ski level is too advanced.
Let's run it one more time
and make sure it is changing.
We'll say beginner,
and I'll hit enter.
And now we see that Penny
Peters is now a beginner skier.
Everything is output to
me in the same order.
We request it here in
my select statement.
So the RecID, first name, last
name, and then that ski level
is beginner.
OK, perfect.
Now up here though, we
need to enter a while loop
to make sure that we keep
asking right until they
enter a valid ski level.
So I'll say, while true, we can
also use a marker variable here
if we wanted.
But I want to run this
part of the program
over and over again until we
break once we have updated
the employee table,
committed the changes,
and then we break out of it.
So let's go ahead
and run this again.
12389.
Thank you for answering
your employee ID.
What is your
current skill level?
We'll say beginner.
And I'll hit enter.
Now we'll see here that Penny
Peters is now a beginner.
Let's try it one more time.
12389.
This time, let's say
advanced, or let's
say a bunch of
random shenanigans.
And it says,
invalid skill level.
Please try again.
Let's do one more time.
Invalid skill level.
Please try again.
Now let's make sure
it's not case sensitive.
I'm going to say
capital A expert.
I run it.
And it still runs for me
because it lowered expert
to be all lowercase, which is
what I had here in my options,
in my list of values
that it could be, OK?
All right.
Perfect.
Now I need to output to
them as denoted above.
Thank you, first name.
Your ski level is now ski level.
OK.
So I know based upon
what's outputting to me,
that first name has the first
index value in this tuple.
So I'll say print f strings.
Thank you.
And use the 0 or the one
index value of Penny.
Thank you, Penny.
Your new ski level is.
And then I will use the third
index position here of expert.
OK, perfect.
Now I run this.
What is your employee ID?
I paste it in.
12389.
Thank you for entering
your employee ID 12389.
Let's make sure
that we say Penny
is going to be an intermediate
now, and we'll hit enter.
Thank you, Penny.
Your new skill
level is advanced.
Oh, That's.
Not what we want.
Let us see here.
Want to watch that
one more time.
Something went awry there.
All right.
Let's look at 12389.
We're looking at
Penny's information.
What is your
current skill level?
We want to change
it to intermediate.
OK.
Oh, jeez.
I use your current ski level is
x3, which is actually stored up
here in this program, right?
The x is the output returning.
X is the tuple of--
Penny's tuple right
here outputting to me.
And the third index
position of x is advanced.
So I need to change
this to be y.
So now let's try it again.
I'm like, this was working.
12389.
Let's change it now
to intermediate.
Now I run it.
Thank you, Penny.
Your new ski level
is intermediate.
OK.
Let's try all one
more time here.
What is your employee ID?
I'm going to hit enter,
like I'm using a blank.
Nothing entered.
You must enter your employee ID.
So it's validating that
the entry is not blank.
Then I'm going to enter
some string values.
Well, actually, let
me put like 7 here.
And it says must
enter an integer.
Now I actually enter an integer.
Then here, what is
your current ski level?
If I just hit enter here,
it says invalid ski level.
I must enter at least something.
So if I say super
beginner and I hit enter,
it says invalid ski level.
Please try again.
Now if I say, you know what?
We're going to end
up that Penny's
going to be advanced, just
like as we were instructed
on the first one.
Then we see here,
thank you, Penny.
Your new ski level is advanced.
So that's what we have for
this in class assignment today.
Two awesome programs
that utilize
a ton of what we've done
thus far in the class.
And I hope this has been
really helpful for you
as we've worked through this.
Thanks for being an awesome
class and for your hard work.
Take care.